the memo news sparked a Twitter response
from the president for a change I didn't
even know he had a Twitter again James
Comey memos just out and show clearly
there was no collusion and no
obstruction also he leaked classified
information Wow will the witch-hunt
continue Jonathan Turley is a lawyer he
knows the answer to that and
professional Constitution a professor of
constitutional law at George Washington
University which is over $70,000 a year
I looked at that and they don't know if
I'm much aid it's a deal
okay there's a deal but you're there so
it makes it worth it so what do we learn
now Jonathan that we didn't know before
this book published that has you really
intrigued well it confirms many things
that some of us have been saying you
know for over a year he's had many
supporters who have been saying things
that I think are facially simply
unsupportable one of them is that these
were some type of personal diary that
they were his personal notes he
continues to maintain that and that's
facially ridiculous I mean if you look
at these memos they're not to him
they're not memos to the file they're
memos to other FBI officials and he's
actually stating in one of the memos how
he wants to do the preliminary
classification and giving it to these
other fischels for their input these are
not personal records but also the FBI
itself has said this is FBI material so
you have someone who was fired as the
director of the FBI
removing seven documents from the FBI
four of which were deemed to have
classified information and then giving
them to a friend for the purpose of
leaking them to the media that's a very
serious set of facts and it doesn't
exactly speak to the ethical leadership
model that call me has been you know a
proponent of so when President Trump
sits there is the businessman turned
brand new politician and says what's
going on with Comey he's a leaker what's
going on with mccabe he's a liar what's
going on I think there's a bias at the
FBI Peter struck Lisa page yes yes yes
and yes his instincts were right on this
well I think that when it comes to Comey
many of his criticisms have been borne
out as with McCabe now it doesn't mean
that the president hasn't made his own
mistakes but he's been blessed by the
critics that he has inherited
and I think that with regard to McCabe
it's a very strong argument for for a
charge it's the very case that he and
others brought against Flynn
he was part of that investigation
initially his situation seems more
serious but with regard to Comey you
know there's other problems with this
one is why would he give this to his
friend what we now know is that various
FBI officials had the document so this
wasn't gonna be destroyed he knew it was
going to go to investigators it was
already in the hands of investigators
but instead in giving it to Congress or
leaving it with the investigators he
chose to give it to a friend to leaked
to the media why it wasn't going to help
the investigation was gonna hurt it
because he just told Trump this these
documents exist what is the answer it
seems is that it was to his advantage
and that's why he did it and because the
president act angrily in their
one-on-one sessions and asked for
certain things he assumes that means
he's guilty or Democrats assume that
thinks he's guilty actually that might
be a human reaction they accuse you of
cavorting with prostitutes that could
become international news and by the way
the worst news is your wife could find
out and he expressed that in the 101
meetings and that emerged also he said
pursue any satellite problems or anybody
that worked with me and he writes I
assumed that meant people that work for
him they may have colluded with Russia
follow that path that really didn't get
out into these memos with public well I
think that much of this is now going to
be public and we're going to for the
first time see a complete record but one
of the more interesting aspects about
commis conduct with regard to these
memos and his book is that he seems to
have put the investigation as into a
secondary position running a tell-all
book while the investigation is ongoing
and you're a principal witness is not
helping the investigation any more than
leaking those memos were they helped Jim
Comey Jonathan Turley we have to tax you
almost every day into your legal
knowledge in order to keep up with an
investigation that is like no other
thanks so much sir thank you Brian